so you want to play dark souls 3 but you  prefer the faster action of blood-borne  no problem Lord Gwyn has answered your  prayers with the thief class and thanks  to a live stream from developer from  software we got to see it in action the  stream showed off the combat you've come  to expect from the souls games with  plenty of back stabs and spilled blood  what's new is a rapid fire bow attack  one of the new soul art moves if the  shrinking mana bar is any indication the  thief also uses some mana to perform a  special dodge so it looks like he has  quite a few tricks up his sleeve the  video is set in an area similar to  blood-borne hem with charnel Lane so  we'll have to see what else the level  has in store for us when the game  releases on March 24th until then you  can stick with gamespot for all the Dark  Souls 3 news we're like a bonfire for  the Internet